طلب الاتحاد الاوروبي واسرائيل بوقفه
محاولاتها للاستيلاء على ممتلكات الكرايس
المسيحيه في القدس الشرقيه وشدد بيانو
الاتحاد الاوروبي على وقف على ان وقفه
محاولات الاستيلاء على ممتلكات الكنائس
المسيحيه هو امر واجب ذلك لانها تشكل
تهديدا خطيرا للتعايش السلمي بين الديانات
السماويه الثلاث في القدس وداع الى حمايه
الوضع الراهن والاماكن المقدسه في القدس
الشرقيه بما في ذلك المسيحيه مؤكدا وجوب
الحفاظ على المكانه الخاصه وطابع القدس
وبلدتها القديمه
من رام الله تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره
جيفارا المديري طبعا هذا البيان شديد
اللهجه من الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن ما هي
خلفيه استيلاء اسرائيل على كنائس
المسيحيين في القدس
انه ياتي بعد اقل من 24 ساعه على تسلم
حكومه نتنياهو سده الحكم في اسرائيل والتي
من اركانها بالطبع
وهما اركان الاستيطان خاصه في القدس ما
كان قد حدث انه يوم الاربعاء الماضي عدد
من المستوطنين ووفقها الكنيسه الروم
الارثوذكس هم من منظمه العاده الاستيطانيه
قاموا بالاستيلاء على قطعه ارض في حي همم
سلوان في الملاصق بالطبع لاصوار البلده
القديمه استولى بالقوه على هذه القطعه وهي
خمسه دونمات وكانت الكنيسه قد اجرتها منذ
اوائل القرن الماضي لعائله سمرين والتي
تقوم باستصلاحها على مدار اكثر من 100
ولا زالت حتى اليوم الكنيسه بالطبع اعتبرت
ان ما تقوم به اسرائيل هي محاولات متواصله
للاستيلاء على ممتلكات سواء كنيسه الروم
الارثوذكس التي لها املاك وعقارات واراضي
كبيره جدا في القدس بشطريها الشرقيه
والغربي وايضا باقي الكنائس
المسيحيه وبالتالي همم البيان الذي صدر عن
ممثل على الاتحاد الاوروبي كان واضح بانه
تم اصداره بالتنسيق مع ممثلي كافه الدول
الاتحاد الاوروبيه والبعثات الاوروبيه في
القدس ورام الله انه موقف موحد اتجاه
اسرائيل رساله واضحه بانه يجب حمايه
الممتلكات
المسيحيه تحديدا وعدم تغيير واقع القدس
خاصه ما يحدث في البلده القديمه وبالتالي
هو اشاره ايضا مبطنه الى المقدسات
المسيحيه والا التي تتعرض
للانتهاكات وهي انتهاكات متوسطه الجزيره